at the last minute uh uh
to join us on the on the panel uh aram
of course was the
was the inaugural speaker in this series
and he he's worked extensively on on
algorithms including
of course the hill algorithm for linear
linear algebra
and then um finally uh
matthias troyer uh is joining us from
from his yacht in
uh i don't know where where are you
matthias uh
i'm close to to the
canadian border to to steward island
great so this morning eckhart here and
i have reception because the antenna is
way up on
the the dip
master and that way i cannot escape
wide range without that antenna i could
not have called in
i could relax and have lunch
but now i'm here with you and that's
great great
great to have you back mattia as you
remember matthias was was uh
gave the colloquium two or three weeks
ago and
[Music]
he's of course taught long and hard
about what you can and can't do in
near-term quantum computers or even even
longer-term ones so um uh just starting
off this
this panel i'd like like to um
uh you know invite uh the panelists to
give
give short two to three minute uh
reactions to ignacio's talks uh talk as
well as to discuss some of the
main themes which which were
you know first you know the theme that
he ended on which was digital versus
analog
simulation you know is there a way that
we we can meaningfully
talk about um uh what happens
you know uh is there is there a way to
talk about asymptotically what would
happen with
analog simulation and whether one can
get advantage
uh with analog simulations um
and also you know how these would scale
with
with uh as as the system size goes up
and and of course then then there are
then there are questions um
about um analog simulations you know in
terms of
uh um well since we have
great experimentalists on the panel you
know what what are the
challenges and possibilities with with
uh with uh
experiments and quantum simulation as
well as
eventually where can we go with them you
know beyond applications in science
which are obviously quite
important so uh possibly can we
you know ima emanuel would you like to
kick this off
sure i can i can start uh well thanks
for having me on the panel and um
yeah so maybe i touch on this digital
versus analog
side first and um so my feeling is and
this was maybe substantiated also with
with
work that was done actually with
matthias and andrew daly and matthias
can comment on that work later on
is that if you can implement a certain
problem right now on these noisy
intermediate scale quantum devices in an
analog way
then probably for sure you have an
advantage in doing it that way
uh in in terms of how long you can
simulate for example the dynamics of the
quantum system
how good you can simulate the dynamics
of the quantum system so
from this comparison with matthias what
we found was that you know the amount of
gates and qubits you need to do it in a
digital fashion
quite far is surpasses anything that's
possible right now
so so the problem is of course the the
caveat is the if
if you can implement the problem of
course the nice thing with the digital
approach is
in principle it can be universal but of
course well we know in practice that
means you need full error correction
but so that also has an if attached to
it but
but it is more flexible it can do more
things that can that you might not be
able to implement directly
so i think that that puts i think places
for me the point you know if you can
realize your problem in an analog way
right now on the devices we haven't
probably for the next few years also if
we
have this step to go towards fault
tolerant quantum computers
this will be a main area of application
for these devices and
making scientific discoveries beyond
trivial solving trivial problems i mean
you know
where we really will have see new things
coming out learn new things
push theory i think this is really going
to push the frontier uh
in this field great uh thanks thanks
emmanuel
actually um i think it might be nice to
alternate
uh experimentalists and theories but i i
just wanted to pick up on something you
said about um
well digital uh simulation of course
would be universal
um and um um
so i just wanted to throughout the you
know
one one good thing about analog
simulation
um also being programmable to some
extent
you know and and so could there be a
notion of
actual um you know some sort of you know
universality even in the absence of
error correction you know could could it
be programmable enough to be
well maybe either universal or at least
or at least a very flexible kind of
a quantum computer that was analog even
though it was not
uh you know there was not error
correction
but um okay possibly uh
um uh shall we move on to aram uh would
you like to
i think so thanks much for having me on
the panel and um
nacio is a very nice talk thanks for
that uh
yeah so i have a few a few thoughts
about simulation
which i don't know how actionable any of
them are but
one thing that occurs to me is that you
know as computer scientists we're used
to
scaling with problem size but maybe for
physical simulation
the precision scaling is more important
you know i have
colleagues with lattice qcd who are
similar trying to simulate nuclei and
they only have to get through the
periodic table and then they're done but
the
you know the the precision scale in some
ways is is more daunting than the
the size scaling and also as the
physical system gets larger
you know it doesn't unl most things are
not like quantum computers they don't
remain coherent
on very large length scales um so that
seems
i don't know fully how to how to grapple
with that challenge uh and there's some
relation between precision and
dimensionality like if you talk about
increasing the number of orbitals
right then that's a that's a way of
getting a precision but that seems like
another
one thing to be thinking about another
thing i was thinking related to the
digital versus analog question
one way to think about an analog
simulator is that it's imperfectly
programmable uh of course which which
means
that you can access some range of
hamiltonians
but but one
one thing that comes up in quantum
simulations is we have a target
evolution and maybe it's
within the range of what we what could
be achieved but we don't know how to
program it
so for example we do a trotter evolution
even though maybe there exists a better
way to get there because we don't know
how to get
uh you know we don't know know how else
to come up with a gate sequence
and so you could imagine that you have
let's say an
analog quantum computer where there's
some always-on interaction
and then there's some other term that
you can you can turn with a dial
and you're trying to drive to a
particular point
and there are uh there are trotter
errors that are that are high order
terms
and you could get rid of them if you
took
exponential time to do a full classical
simulation and figure out the optimal
path
but of course that would defeat the
whole purpose of the simulation and so
we may get into situations where
there's there's sort of some kind of
triple trade-off between
you know how the how much compilation
time you want to take
what kind of of error you end up with
uh and you know how many quantum
resources you want to you want to devote
to the problem
and that's another another thing which
i i feel i'm bringing up these points
because they're interesting but you know
they may
they may be hard to study it may be hard
to make any progress on them uh and
um the final thing i think will be
interesting to study is uh combining
these things with classical simulators
which which some people have done
uh you know combining classical and
quantum tensor network contractions
uh but there seems like a lot of room
there still
thanks uh thanks aaron to
misha
so thank you mesh for invitation again
and actually uh thanks for running this
great
seminar series and also to ignite you
for inspiring
talk so maybe i will try to kind of
pick up a little bit on your last
question about kind of from
programmability aspect so indeed you
could kind of quantify
you know almost all quantum machines in
terms of like several
axes so one of them you know could be
number of qubits you know
another one is you know coherence and
the fourth axis is you know
programmability and so
in principle if you have analog quantum
simulators which are which are fully
programmable
they are you know by definition
universal in fact you can run
i mean at that point the difference
between digital
and analog basically disappears you can
always run analog
you know device as a secret you know
sequence of
of of the gates and um
what i would say for that is that
perhaps an interesting challenge and
it's also related to
maybe some of the other things you
mentioned kind of applications beyond
you know quantum physics but i think
it's an interesting challenge for maybe
computer science
to try to really start you know thinking
i mean it's in a way you know this kind
of digital quantum computers it's
relatively easy to map onto conventional
kind of gates and sequences
i think an analog devices are kind of a
different you know beast a little bit
the in the in
in kind of in the town right and um
[Music]
i i actually think that this is a very
special opportunity
because as emmanuel said that in terms
of let's say
you know i mean pick some you know
interesting parameter i don't know
degree of entanglement you know system
size you know
uh you know like the duration of the
kind of evolution right i would say you
know
in particular programmable analog
devices you know programmable quantum
simulators in general
um are capable of kind of solving you
know scientific
you know problems and the problems in
quantum physics
at the level where i think you know kind
of conventional quantum computers have
really
hard time to compete right now so and i
think that is really i think
it's a very very special opportunity you
know in our field
you know and i think this kind of
opportunity is maybe kind of twofold on
one hand
you know this is um you know something
we talked about couple of weeks ago
about this kind of age of quantum
discovery
where i think you know basically we can
you know push the systems to corners of
hilbert space where no one has been
and you know frankly at this point you
know whenever you go to this new corner
you always discover something
you could then go back and ask okay can
you somehow devise some you know tensor
network to simulate it and
sometimes you can but nonetheless you
know to a priori you wouldn't know that
you could
find something there right but on the
other hand you know
if i think if we start building this
bridge to two years
and kind of you know more and in a more
more substantial way perhaps we could
also start
asking you know and answering the
questions can the systems be used beyond
just the main of quantum physics where
they are very very natural
great thank thanks uh misha that's
really interesting
um matias
would love to hear what you have to say
hey so
listening to the [ __ ] talk
but
i had negative 52 comments
one was about the question about ground
states versus dynamics
my view there is that ground states are
classically easier
ground states is successful but
if you looked at your
for decades and centuries but it's not
because we don't want to study
dynamics but that negativity the
dynamics is typically
hard too hard we don't have yet the new
theories
and dynamics always for that may be that
we don't yet have
or that we didn't have ways to to
actually
get the control data
and so with the negative simulators
we have now
they're there is
a big chance to use them to actually
simulate here simple systems that will
then allow us
to discover your new theories
for negative the the dynamics
and since that's the negative
classically
and easy quantumly i think that could
be a great way of starting there
generally
we would love to have a negative machine
that can do do negative any model
it should be negative sufficient to
have something to give to analog for now
to study many models and like for
the
the the damage case use the results
of the of the of the
machines we have now
to give us your data that can
be used to validate or calibrate
new classical methods so i think
the the this
lots we can do because what would i do
if i
had a gate model the machine
with
f 200 year cubits i would use it
to start the dynamics i would use it to
to study spin models
to see hubbard models but those those
those nuggets we can do now
to do the chemistry will take me it
will take something much bigger so it
starts with the same models
and that's uh that's [ __ ] what we can
do
now already so i think we should use
the machines where they are
good namely for
to find new physics hey
thanks a lot uh matthias so uh i i want
to turn
uh to ignacio now to for his reactions
but before that
let me just say once again um you know
something
about dynamics that maybe maybe
uh maybe i'm just not you know seeing it
clearly as a computer scientist but
you know to my my view is that
ground states uh you know hold still
long enough that we can look at them
and look at them repeatably but dynamics
in quantum systems you know it seems
well you know you have this you have
this trajectory you cannot even see
or you can you you can do a sample from
the from from the final distribution
so it would really help me to understand
you know scenarios in in what way
is is dynamics going to be useful how
would you profitably use it you know
once we
once we are able to do those simulations
so
uh you know at some point uh it would be
it would be interesting
so i'd say what you say is just white is
so
super hard to actually have data for
that why
we can't really remodel it but but
but we would need to do it for transport
simulation
for magnetization changes and nucleation
from your faces
but your hard drives here switch bits
for example so
there's lots of things that we can't
really measure because it's so fast
that's why we don't have the theory yet
because we we can't check it and test it
but since we can now on the
machines things here that
your mission builds and others built and
you have the
manual and so on then that's where we
can learn about
dynamics phase nucleation transport
transient defects in transport the many
open questions there
thanks thanks matthias ignacio i'd love
to
hear what okay so i think that i could
not agree
more with what was has has been said and
actually i skipped one of the
transparencies and i'm going to go
through that a little bit too to show my
agreement
uh so at the end i wanted to say so why
do we want
quantum simulation so this was my last
transparency so what
what if we have now a quantum simulator
that has 100
200 cubits what can we do with it
and so one of the so i think that i
would say four things at least
so one of them is to solve specific
problems
okay so maybe somebody has a hover model
and with a classical computer with ed
exact calculation we can only go to 40
qubits and so with 100 kiwis we may
learn a little bit more and then
go a little bit in the direction of uh i
mean
getting more information i mean
improving a little bit upon the the
classical computers
another one is provide understanding so
sometimes in
in many body systems when you have a
physical phenomenon that you observe you
measure
you would like to get around it and to
try it and what happens if you change
something
and to have a mechanistic model of
understanding it and i think that these
quantum simulators is really like that i
mean you see
and one example is what happened uh
like like in in high energy physics if
you start talking to people in high
energy physics it's very abstract but
whenever you start talking about tensor
networks or quantum computers then you
see it in a completely different way it
acts uh
different a different perspective which
i think that from the scientific point
of view you can open
some doors another one is what the
manual says curiosity driven research
okay so you can start just checking
looking for new phenomena that you could
not even imagine that they would exist i
mean misha
has an example of that with his scars
and so you can just try something and
they pop up many things that come up but
the most important part and i
insist that in many talks for me is
benchmarking series i mean material was
talking about
time dependent theories but also time
independent series i mean we as you know
we're
working also on tensor networks and
developing algorithms of tensor networks
and one of the problems that we are
facing is that there is no way of
benchmarking in many cases
so you have sometimes a network and you
think that it will be it will work
and then you have some arguments why it
will work but if there was an
experiment with hundred qubis or 200
qubits that you know that it works or
or may not work whatever you could
change i mean check with that i think
that
this would allow us to develop many many
methods numerical methods or
computational theoretical methods
that at the moment we don't have so
working theories with experimentalists
in that sense of experimentalism
providing
this wonderful tool new ideas new
discoveries and we theories i mean
bouncing bouncing back these ideas and
and with new uh
algorithms and methods i think that this
could give a huge advance to the
development of many body theory in
general and i think that this is the
most important one
rather than some specific examples i
think that this development that they
they can allow us that it has been
missing so far
oh that's great um
yeah thank you um uh
maybe uh i should see if um
uh if anybody in the audience has a
there's a question
so um i don't see any questions here
there is a question from rob cook
so it says that our speaker made
connections between extensive and
intensive quantities
and robustness to errors in quantum
simulation
i believe there is a conjecture that
asserts roughly that anything you can
compute on a quantum computer without
error correction can be
computable on a classical computer but
i'm wondering if finalists any comment
in that
i i don't know the conjecture but i
think one challenge with formulating
something like this is that
error correction does not have a precise
definition
um you know it's error correction is
just a kind of software technique we use
um and so there's no real bright line
between
quantum computers with and without it um
i mean there are some heuristic
algorithms like uh
isaac kim and also kim and swingle have
some algorithms for
um doing certain kinds of quantum
simulations that
of systems that have have bounded
correlation length and so you might say
that if those
it's possible that the arguments that
lead those to work quantumly would also
lead a classical simulator to work as
well um
but i think i think if this were true it
probably would be in some
in some special cases um
so i think uh
and i guess one more thing i'll say is
this kind of gets back to some of the
precision questions so
um for this is
one thing that we know for random
circuits i'm just going to say this
because we we know it rigorously
is that if you have random circuits like
the kind that google did for the quantum
supremacy experiment
and each gate has a error rate epsilon
then there's a classical simulation and
the run time
is like exponential and one over epsilon
or exponential and one over epsilon
squared
i think extension on one over epsilon
and so that is
uh you know polynomial time if epsilon
is constant
um but you know if epsilon is 1 over 100
then that's still going to be out of the
range of any of any classical computer
so it may well be that if we don't do
error correction and we just let the
errors accumulate
um then there is some
you know formally speaking there's some
polytime classical algorithm
and still that could lead an enormous
amount of room for
uh for big quantum advantage
okay thanks uh um
there's a there's a question in the chat
uh
john lew asks um
you know about about this question about
um
you know fermionic type simulations like
electronic structure problems so
wouldn't it be an advantage to using a
fermionic
quantum simulator or what what would the
i guess just translating it what are the
prospects of
actually actually uh implementing that
efficiently in the lab
well that's that's what we're doing
that's exactly what we're doing and
marcos kreiner our team in munich others
are working on this
by directly using feminic particles that
simulate electrons
so you don't have to map this problem
onto you know in a standard
qubit-based quantum computer you would
have to map the electronic problem onto
the qubit
system and that already carries an
overhead with it in the number of qubits
and the number of gate operations
but for us we can do it directly so we
just have the feminine problem directly
so that's of course a huge advantage in
terms of how far we can then push this
so for this specific problem i think
it's a very good example
if you can implement more complex terms
there
you really are pushing this in a very
very interesting direction and right now
i think the
simulators are at the point where
they're just about i think
uh you know on on on the same level with
the most advanced simulations so i think
getting a little bit colder for example
in temperatures
already i think would bring the
simulators into a regime where again it
would push theory i think this is always
back and forth as matthias has explained
very interesting back and forth between
theory and
experiment and but now we're really
already at this very interesting point
where we're challenging theory already
to
to come up with the results i want to
just add also one thing i think is very
important to
for me was very important to learn that
you know we have through these quantum
simulations we have learned how to use
new observables
to to to characterize quantum many body
states
especially like a non-standard non-local
observables i mean
misha had very nice recent results on
this we have been studying this
also for a long time now and really this
i think broadened the mindset of the
whole theory community because the
people were not thinking of this the
condensed metaphysis
they were thinking in the standard
two-point correlation functions what you
can measure in a neutron scattering
experiment maybe
and really i think this brings a whole
new set of uh
you know discussion to the table of what
we can measure and how we can understand
those phases of matter
also dynamics of course i think this is
very exciting and finally one final
point um when you asked why is it
interesting dynamics
i think we should also mention that
dynamics is very interesting for
creating interesting resource states
for example for metrology this is
something that can be super useful
application maybe is an outcome
if we can create metrologically
interesting resource states
for clocks for measurements and that's
happening i mean adam kaufman and manuel
enders are working on these things so
for example
and this is a very exciting direction
for me as well
um i see so
and and just to just to go back to the
point you started with um
about the fermionic um simulators so
so is could you could you uh quantify
that a little bit so
you know if you were to take a
a suitable problem of your choice you
know what are the kinds of resources you
would need to actually
solve that and how how close are things
now in terms of
what resources you can bring to bear in
the in the lab
well so typically the system sizes are a
few hundred uh
particles right now i think we'll see a
few and for bosons we've already moved
to few thousands and i think this will
happen for fermions as well soon
so a few hundred we can detect
spin up spin down holes doubly occupied
sites so we can make a full
measurement in that that occupation base
has been resolved on every lattice site
so it's like
getting a snapshot from a quantum monte
carlo simulation basically
and from that you try to construct uh
interesting correlation functions
so that's what we're doing in the lab
and uh yeah that that's
that's basically where the systems stand
right now
very interesting
um are there
are there any other
there's a question by frank frank was
strategy on
one q a so it says uh
metropolis type algorithms have acquired
a quasi-monopoly for
simulating thermal states of classical
interactance interacting systems
mainly because of existence of smart
update schemes
what is the prospect of quantum monte
carlo methods that ignacio talked about
in that respect like how do you design
interesting updates
so i i don't know who should answer that
matthias is the expert here on quantum
montana
important to always have the markov
chain again they did mix rapidly
and when we looked at the
top policy algorithm first would be
that might mix very slowly
and then when we looked at it we found
out that
that's not the case that it's extremely
the the the fast in mixing
and mixing between those two can be done
very easily
by a local clear sigma c operator so
it's extremely easy to mix those states
quantumly so the answer
is yes we have to to look at the other
algorithms that mix fast
but the [ __ ] classically
situation might be misleading because
what we do is we take and
take it and get the eigenstate we apply
a local update
but then again we project on to a
negative eigenstate
and that projection is totally non-local
and because of that i think it will will
mix much much better than classical
algorithms but that's something
we need to look into much more
thanks mathias uh
sorry i think we should um you know this
is pretty close to
uh we should bring this to an end but i
just wanted to very quickly ask one more
question for the experimentalist uh
emmanuel and misha
so in in terms of doing doing um
uh you know interesting simulations
what what do you think is holding you
know what's what's the bigger obstacle
is it number of cube
so is it is it the is it um
somehow the fidelity of the operations
where do you see things going and
how do you how do you see things
progressing from here
so yeah so i already mentioned i guess
in my mind you know
there are kind of three axes which you
know
you basically have to push the system
simultaneously
you know okay number of qubits you know
means a simple one to understand but i
mean if you have a lot of qubits but
their coherence is very bad
you know it there is nothing you don't
gain anything
right but if your taxes as i already
indicated this is a programmability
access
right so you know and you know
regardless of what you want to do if you
want to do quantum computing of course
you want to have it more and more
universal
if you want to have uh you know do
quantum simulations you would like to
basically implement more and more
complex models
and
you know basically these are the three i
think kind of very important
you know directions which have to really
be you know kind of advanced and
you know maybe also connected to one of
the earlier question questions you mesh
about quantum dynamics you know i would
say
that you know dynamic you know quantum
dynamics especially non-equilibrium
dynamics
is i would say really the central issue
in the entire field of quantum
information
and it's you know i mean like you know
this was already i'm kind of repeating
what others have said you know
i mean basically you know creating
entangled states
which are somehow you know like you know
or robust new zealand right i mean
entanglement is clearly a resource
but if you have your system entirely
formalized i mean this is not a useful
entanglement right
i mean how many other states which are
you know have interesting entanglement
properties
and useful but you know they are still
kind of in some way controllable
right so i mean what about meta-stable
states a lot of phenomena in natural
look i mean
the entire you know both einstein
condensation is not a ground state
you know the one that what you know the
starting point of all
experiments by manuel and others is not
a ground state of the system but
nevertheless it's a super useful
uh kind of you know very relevant kind
of state
and you know of course i mean that also
connects to what
uh both matthias and ignacio mentioned
is that you know right now our
understanding of this non-equilibrium
phenomenon our theoretical understanding
is really really limited
you know and you know the hope is really
that through improving this coherence
number of qubits programmability uh and
also improving measurement schemes you
know
looking at you know ways to quantify the
entangled quantum matter
which is extremely non-trivial right
that's a hope we can really
you know push you know also both
theories
you know physics theories but maybe also
you know computer science theories
you know yeah great uh
thanks that that was very helpful yeah
um well thank you uh you know thanks
thanks uh you know all the panelists and
to ignacio for for a
wonderful discussion um i have posted
the
uh a gather town link for anybody who
would like to
you know join for uh for an extended
discussion but uh
but um yeah i just want to
thank you all and and
you next week
thank you thank you great to see you all
bye everyone bye